hello why you should specialize this
really goes for anything and everything
and it's not always obvious that
specializing is the right choice excuse
me while I adjust this camera
I am Li programmer in case you haven't
figured that out and I like being a
programmer I haven't done it for very
long like four years four and a half
years
and I've already managed to accomplish
quite a bit as to develop a program
that's doing quite well in github to the
general public and managed to land a
pretty good job in the software
development community research and
development and to I don't know whatever
anyway I feel like the only way I've
been able to accomplish all these things
is by deciding to specialize and my
choice of specialization is C++ so you
can ask me pretty much anything about
C++ and I'll probably know the answer or
probably know how to do it and the only
reason I do it is because I non-stop
research C++ non-stop program in C++ if
I were to switch to a different language
every once in a while and learn a little
bit of this a little bit of that I would
only know a little bit of C++ and I
would not have been able to develop my
program that is doing well on github and
I would not have been able to land this
job I know for sure I wouldn't be able
to play on this job because the
interview was very C++ specific and had
to whiteboard some stuff and C++
I knew
I knew how to do all this stuff because
I had done it so many times because I
had hashed it over so many times because
the question that I was asked was a
pretty common thing but if you've only
done it once or twice you won't remember
off the top of your head without looking
it up but if you've done it I don't know
10 20 30 times and you have to support
it in a program you've already made and
you know how to do it and you can nail
it
and you can talk all kinds of shop about
think you're specializing in and really
really let other people know that you
are as good as it sounds like because
you know all these little intricate
details it's not like that if you don't
specialize
so that's pretty much the reason why you
should pick a language and you should
stick with it now I'm not saying you
shouldn't try other ones
there is definitely value and exploring
other languages but you should still
have a main one that is your the one you
want to know every single little thing
about and the others it should be more
of like your your wants to dabble in to
go do some hello worlds and maybe some
small projects we don't spend too much
time on them
because then you're taken away from your
main
this can be related to anything for this
particular video this particular channel
talking about
a coding language or a programming
language but I remember back in the day
when I played World of Warcraft
it was the same same thing all the
biggest guilt that were conquering the
biggest latest bosses and getting all
the best gear they would only accept
people who played on their mains
primarily
you can have vaults but if you spend a
significant amount of time on your alts
you'll be rejected and the exceptions to
that we're about the same as the
exceptions in real life
okay you can go branch out and get
really good at something else but not
until you're like at the maximum you can
be under Maine
it's interesting how the concepts of Wow
and becoming today top-notch Raider or
like the same as programming
I never really thought of that till I
started saying in this video
but it is sort of true like it in well
once you're this out was for me anyway
once you're made was decked as he could
be you really had nothing more to gain
playing him you were as good as you
could get pretty much you had all the
gear you can possibly get pretty much
then it's time to start playing on your
own
and I think it's a lot like that for
programming too once you're about as
good as you can get at your language
it's really not much more for you to
learn
then it's time to start branching out
really branching out hard it picking
another secondary mate
if you choose to specialize in something
everything surrounding it it's easier
you get really really good at one
language the other languages become
easier because a lot of the stuff like
it's similar
so you already have some some parallel
knowledge that sort of relates so if you
get really good to C++ and then you go
to learn Python
usually it's the other way around
usually start with something like Python
but anyway the point is if you're really
going to C++ you've never touched Python
as soon as you pick up Python you're
gonna know all these little things about
programming about structuring data and
about the order the way things should go
and just little stuff like that you're
gonna know it already because it's good
a lot of the stuff is like Rojas
knowledge
it's like that a lot for other stuff
real life too
you're really good at one thing you
suddenly have all this all this
additional knowledge that you can bring
to other places too when you go do
something else you take all that cross
knowledge and you're already ahead of
the game so it really pays to just stick
with one thing and it pays it more than
just getting good at that one thing you
would turn also get pretty good at all
the things that are sort of like so
there it is thanks for watching my video
I hope you like and subscribe if you
want to see more videos like this don't
forget to hit the bell so you can come
notified when I upload them sorry for
the background noise or maybe some
people enjoy
I am driving right now that 10
make these sort of videos
because I have a lot of time to think
and ideas come to mind when I'm driving
see in the next one peace out